please welcome the amazing hilarious my
old friend seth myers
[Applause]
how old do you think we were when we
first met on like snl um i think you
were probably 25 and i was like 13. no
i'm kidding
no i mean you must have no well so i was
27 when i started the show so i bet you
were there the first few years so 28.29
oh my gosh yeah it's crazy it's been a
really long it's been a really long time
i mean i remember us being at like after
parties you know like young carefree
yeah you know i get hungover thinking
about those parties
i stopped drinking
yeah such a good time at those after
parties they were so fun yes okay well
we were talking upstairs about the fact
that you just had lettermen
um celebrating 40 years of late night
yes i mean
how was that you know i love him yes it
was a lovely conversation and it did it
was the 40th anniversary of
you know the late night franchise and of
course it wouldn't be around if it
wasn't for him so it was a cool thing to
do that was where i developed yeah
that was where i developed my crush for
him was on late night was on your
beloved franchise yes i thought he was
so hot i know i you know
fingers crossed there's someone out
there who's developing a crush on me
based on late night
it's possible right seth i remember from
snl when we were all young everyone
always had questions thank you so much i
mean that's what i'll tell my kids
tonight yes you should you know what
mommy isn't the only one
women have been hot for me forever
anyway where's your duck you were such a
catch and you married a beautiful woman
i did a very good job yeah she's a real
cat and we we're making good kids and i
think that's how you know uh there she
is that's um and that's a hat she wears
every day can i ask like when you first
met her did you know was it a love at
first sight was it a friendship first
so it's a true story you know uh we met
at chris kattan's wedding you remember
chris kattan i just saw chris at jimmy's
valet yeah there you go he was just
there and he and i have a saying called
rooftops because he and i both got drunk
with a bunch of friends and jumped off
rooftops together yeah
so that's like i think it's really good
you stop drinking
[Laughter]
rooftops every time we see each other
rooftops
in all fairness it was into pools it
wasn't i probably should have added
that's a very good thing to add so
you're at katana yeah but this is a true
story we met the first night uh you know
friday rehearsal dinner night and then
we sat next to each other at the wedding
and people
we were such a
immediate fit that people were asking us
like how long have you guys been
together and we were like oh we met
yesterday so that's what i see it's like
you guys look like two human puzzle
pieces yeah
well or as rachel dratch said that day
because she was at the wedding uh she
goes oh my god you look like brother and
sister i'm like don't say that
[Music]
you